what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I've done
a coffee I don't have it's not the
morning but I tell you my thoughts and
I'm starting to think that maybe the
premise the name of this channel wasn't
particularly right because half the time
it's not even morning when I film these
but I have a water bottle
the straw is being weird though anyways
before I start don't forget to like the
video subscribe to the channel let's get
started so today I'm going to tell you
guys the story of this crazy lady that
is freaking after me
guys it just seems like there's
something every week like there's just
been craziness so last week you guys
know Destiny was in town
we had the crazy lady threaten
the room and walk out and then the
second crazy lady was named Esther and
she refused to leave when I asked her to
leave
um to the point where I had to call my
front desk asking them to get her to
leave she left before they got there
or like as they got there I think
um
yeah so
this I cannot believe this happened to
me so I thought I was done with her
she's banished for my show I know you
guys have a million comments don't bring
her back y'all
I promise you this crazy woman is not
coming back
step one step two step two
I thought I was done with her I'm living
my life having a good time I am in the
studio and I'm going to let my dog out
my dog's like barking at me blah blah
blah you know you know how [__] are
so the dog
um I need to go let her out and I'm
taking her down the elevator and I go
into the lobby and guess who I see guess
who's there awaiting me
crazy lady the one that at the end of
the show refused to leave her name is
Esther and I'll give you the links to
these videos now she is chatting with
the security guard
uh I keep I keep saying security guard
but I guess the technical term is their
concierge they're not security
I thought they were there to secure the
building but I'm learning now maybe
they're not I don't know what their job
is then
so so I say Esther why are you here
now she says I'm here to see
the concierge now me
I'm thinking that's weird why is this
lady stalking me I mean it's remember
this is past midnight this is like
almost one in the morning this lady is
at the studio
and now she claims she has a like some
sort of relationship with the security
guard
concierge sorry they they really want to
make it clear that they're concierge and
not security
okay so so
um
the security guard can't even talk the
concierge looks at me and he says yeah
like she's with me
she's here to see me
um this is weird so I'm gonna let Ellie
out my dog I go back upstairs and I call
the concierge and I say hey she needs to
leave just so you know she will be
perceived as a threat I will call the
cops and
um she needs to be escorted out of the
building and he then tells me that oh
and I say that she is stalking me now
because what else am I supposed to think
if this lady seemingly has no
relationship with the security guard
other than
there's after the show he also took her
side after the show
um which is weird why would you take
this outside of a crazy lady over a
resident
I call me crazy okay
and
um so
which he then claims later that he was
not taking sides but I don't know what
take watch the video it's in the
description so
whatever I was gonna let that go I
wasn't even gonna do anything about that
I just was like whatever until
now you're letting this crazy lady come
to my building at wee hours of the night
now it's funny because then
um after I have this conversation on the
phone with him
then
um
I
what happened next so yeah he tells me
he she will not leave or that he will
not have scored her out
um that she is that is his opinion that
he's she is not a stalker and that she's
here to see him so this is the
information I have
it's funny he switches up later it's
very funny it's very funny in hindsight
so what do I do I
I write a strongly worded email
I'm just going to read you a little
excerpt from it but I I cannot have my
concierge being friends with the crazy
lady like you need to do that on your
own time you're working
um
today um today I went downstairs to let
my dog out and I saw Esther the guest
there the same person who is stalking me
I informed the security guard that she
needed to be removed from the building
because she was stalking me he's aware
of the situation because he was there
when she was removed the first time in a
scene in the link in the link above
instead of having the stalker removed he
took the stalker's side he then informed
me that it is his opinion that she was
not a stalker I'm a single woman and I
am in fear of my life yet security
failed to remove the stalker from the
premise
the security guard said that the stock
and also she also threatened me during
that video if you watch it
she's talking about bringing people back
to do something some magic [__] she's
gonna like curse me like what the look
you you never know you might think this
is an overreaction but you never know
what crazy people are capable of
um okay sorry he then informed me that
it was his opinion that she was not a
stalker I'm a single woman living alone
and I'm in fear of my life and yet the
security failed to remove the stalker
from the premise the guard said that the
stalker was there to see him why is the
stalker seeing security during business
hours while security is on duty he needs
to be removed immediately as he is not
protecting any of the tenants from the
building if he wishes to date security
threats he should do that on his own
time and not during business hours he's
putting his hormones over the interests
of the tenants when I get back to the
apartment to ask if she had been removed
he again told me he refused to remove
her I am interested in getting my
attorneys involved and I will I'm going
to go to the police with this [__]
um
yeah because that [__] is not acceptable
so
it's literally like it is so scary to me
that this crazy lady is coming to my
apartment
my building at freaking
one in the morning for God knows what
and it's just interesting how
I am the most
agreeable person in the world but you
cannot tell me
that that is not crazy okay and then and
then the freaking
guard is taking this crazy lady side the
other like simps will do anything
later he claims that he does not in fact
know her well if you did not in fact
know her then why did you tell me that
you knew her before
am I supposed to
which is it do you know her do you not
know her
so I don't know let me know what you
guys think I should do with this
situation because I can't have crazy
people showing up at all hours of the
night
um especially ones that know they are
not allowed to come back here
[Music]
um
and I also can't have a front concierge
person that is trying to do whatever
and
is allowing someone that is crazy into
the building
um I don't know I I'm planning on
getting police involved so
just so there's like an official
Complaint on the record so let me know
what you guys think
um
I can't oh my gosh I almost filmed the
video last night but I was gonna start
swearing I was gonna be
oh my gosh I just can't believe that
happened
I'm like laughing a little bit about it
now because you know I like didn't sleep
most last night I was like so frazzled
and I was just scared like it's just
scary and a lot of people don't
really realize like
maybe like the answer is just 24 7
security
um because another thing that happened
was like someone showed up to the studio
again asking to come on the show and
it's like
again guys I I know a lot of you want to
come on the show
um and I don't want to look at that as a
security threat
you know
um but it's really creepy when people
are just
showing up
um because you just don't know what
people are gonna do and especially it's
different like
um there's other content creators in a
similar situation but
you know it's a bit different because
they're they're guys and they can I
there's no guns here so
if I'm in a situation I'm gonna be
forced to like
I don't want to be forced to
do something
crazy you know or like get into a fight
or I don't
I don't want any of that but it's like
if the security of my build or the
concierge of my building is allowing
crazy people in
you know and now they're telling me they
will not allow crazy people in but you
know
um the first time I asked and the second
time I asked I was not listened to so
how do I know in the future
there will be no crazy people allowed
into the building
um
I've sorted it with my shows
because we have we have a security guard
he's going to be here six days a week
um for all the shows and
that'll be good but
outside of that like
I don't know
gosh
this is worse than the whale attack I
think yeah the whale attack was
yeah
that was bad too that was in public so
it's like if it's in public
you're not like scared but
you just you never know you never know
who people know it's just
so I don't know let me know what you
guys think in the comments um let me
know what I should do in terms of like
next steps I think um I've looked at
filing an injunction against hers and um
it looks like it I like I would qualify
for that so
um
yeah I just need to be taking this stuff
seriously when it comes to security and
I just think I'm at the level now where
I just really need to
make sure that's taken care of
um I'm sorry I'm like all over the place
I still can't believe this happened
um like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time